>> Laura: NOW A TALE OF TWO
AMERICAS.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
ONE OF BIDEN’S MAIN SELLING
POINTS IN THE 2020 CAMPAIGN
UNLIKE TRUCK HE HAD EMPATHY
FOR ALL AMERICANS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO WERE STRUGGLING.
>> JOE BIDEN IS A FIGHTER FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS.
>> BIDEN HAS A PLAN TO PUT
AMERICANS BACK TO WORK.
>> THIS IS WHAT DEMOCRATS CARE
ABOUT.
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR AMERICAN
FAMILIES STRUGGLING.
>> VOTERS WERE TELLING ME I
THINK JOE BIDEN CARES ABOUT
ME.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, THAT
WAS ALL A LIE.
HE HAS ONLY BEEN IN OFFICE BY
THREE WEEKS BUT ALREADY UNDER
THE ANTIBUSINESS POLICIES LIKE
THE HALTING OF THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE, MANY OF THE FELLOW
AMERICANS ARE BEING MADE TO
SUFFER.
THINK ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF THE
FALK, ARKANSAS, WHO UNTIL
BIDEN CAME ALONG WERE GRATEFUL
TO HAVE THE GOOD-PAYING JOBS
WITH THE PIPELINE PROJECT.
THEIR INCOMES NOT ONLY MEANT
THEY COULD FEED THE FAMILIES
AND BUILD THEIR FUTURES.
BIDEN COMPLETELY UP-ENDED
THEIR LIVES WITH THE STROKE OF
A PEN.
>> IT’S HARD TO MAKE PLANS
WHEN YOU HAVE ADMINISTRATION
TRYING TO CRUSH YOUR FUTURE!
THIS WAS GOING TO BE THE
FAMILY HOME FOR YOU AND THREE
BOYS.
>> WITHOUT A JOB.
>> NOW YOU DON’T HAVE A JOB.
>> WE WERE BOTH GOING TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THE
KEYSTONE.
TO HAVE THAT FUTURE COMPLETELY
TAKEN AWAY.
JUST BY ONE SIGNATURE.
THE YOUNGEST DAUGHTER IS A
JUNIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL.
SHE IS SUPPOSED TO BE GOING TO
COLLEGE, TOO.
I DON’T KNOW HOW I’M GOING TO
PAY FOR IT.
>> Laura: ABSOLUTELY
HEARTBREAKING.
BIDEN’S KEYSTONE DECISION
ALONE WILL KILL ESTIMATED
11,000 JOBS THIS YEAR.
BUT DON’T WORRY, AMERICA.
ALL THE BRAND NEW GREEN JOBS
BIDEN PROMISED YOU ARE COMING
ANY DAY NOW I’M SURE.
>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO LET THE THOUSANDS OF
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY WORKERS
SUFFER OR WILL DO BE OUT OF
WORK BECAUSE OF THE BIDEN E.O.
WHEN AND WHERE DO THEY GO FOR
THE GREEN JOB?
>> I WELCOME YOU TO PRESENT
YOUR DATA OF THE THOUSANDS OF
THE PEOPLE WHO WON’T GET A
GREEN JOB MAYBE NEXT TIME YOU
ARE HERE YOU CAN PRESENT THAT.
>> Laura: OH, JEN.
IS THAT THE EMPATHY WE WERE
PROMISED IN THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE?
ON THIS ONE ISSUE OF KEYSTONE,
THOUSANDS ARE NOW FRANTICALLY
WORRYING ABOUT HOW THEY WILL
PAY THEIR BILLS.
DOESN’T GET A RAT’S YOU KNOW
WHAT ABOUT THEM.
WE KNOW WHAT BIDEN AND THE
HANDLERS DO CARE ABOUT?
CATERING TO THE RICH DONORS
AND ENRICHING THE SLEAZY
FAMILY MEMBERS.
COMPARE FORTUNE OF THE
KEYSTONE FAMILY TO JOE’S SON
HUNTER.
KEYSTONE WORKERS HAVE WORK
EXPERIENCE.
AND RELEVANT SKILLS.
HUNTER WAS ZERO TALENT OR
SKILLS WAS PAID MILLIONS TO
SIT ON THE BOARD.
HE CASHED IN IN ON THE BIDEN
NAME HE READILY ADMITTED.
>> IF YOUR LAST NAME WAS NOT
BIDEN WOULD YOU BE ASKED TO BE
ON THE BOARD OF BURISMA?
>> I DON’T KNOW.
PROBABLY NOT.
I DON’T THINK A LOT OF THINGS
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED IN MY LIFE
IF MY LAST NAME WASN’T BIDEN.
>> Laura: HOW LUCRATIVE IS
IT TO BE A BIDEN?
LUCRATIVE OR NOT TO PAY
$25,000 A MONTH LUXURY HOME
RENTAL IN VENICE, CALIFORNIA.
NO SIGN HE IS FRETTING ABOUT
COVERING HIS BILLS.
HE IS SO BRAZEN ABOUT NOT
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
BUSINESS DEALINGS HE REMAINS
HEAVILY INVESTED IN A JOINT
VENTURE WITH COMPANIES OWNED
BY THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY.
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO FEEL BETTER
BECAUSE HE IS NOW WORKING TO
UNWIND HIS BUSY RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE MOST POWERFUL GLOBAL
ADVERSARY?
IMAGINE IF THIS WAS ONE OF THE
TRUMP KIDS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE REACTION
WOULD BE.
I’M SURE QUESTIONS WILL BE
ANSWERED IN HIS MEMOIR.
HE LANDED $2 MILLION ADVANCE
FOR A NEW BOOK DEAL WITH SIMON
AND SCHUSTER.
DO YOU THINK ONE OF THE
KEYSTONE WORKERS COULD LAND A
BOOK DEAL FOR A FRACTION OF
THE ADVANCE?
OF COURSE NOT.
JOE’S BROTHER’S FRANK LIVING
LARGE, TOO.
USING HIS CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
WITH HIS BROTHER TO DRUM UP
CLIENTS IN A NEWSPAPER AD.
THE TWO BIDEN BROTHERS HAVE
LONG HELD A COMMITMENT TO
PUSHING ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES.
MY BROTHER IS A MODEL FOR HOW
TO GO ABOUT DOING HIS WORK.
THEY ADD SUBTLEY BIDEN
REPUTATION.
OH, GOD.
THEY SHOULD LAUNCH ANOTHER
100-DAY CHALLENGE.
I ASK ALL AMERICANS TO NAME A
BIDEN FAMILY MEMBER WHO ISN’T
SOMEHOW COMPROMISED.
THIS COUNTRY AND THIS
GOVERNMENT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BELONG TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ALL THE PEOPLE.
DO YOU REMEMBER THE LANGUAGE
FROM THE GETTYSBURG ADDRESS?
GOVERNMENT OF, BY AND FOR THE
PEOPLE?
NOT JUST THE WELL CONNECTED
PEOPLE.
NOT THE RICH PEOPLE.
NOT THE PEOPLE WITH SUPPORTERS
IN THE MEDIA.
NOT THE PEOPLE WITH THE
CONNECTIONS TO FOREIGN
DICTATORS.
NO.
ALL THE PEOPLE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
FOUGHT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
WORKED ON THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE.
BUT TO BIDEN AND HIS TEAM,
MOST AMERICANS ARE RACISTS WHO
ARE DESTROYING THE PLANET.
BIDEN TEAM, PEOPLE ARE
DISPOSABLE AND DISPENSABLE.
THE FOLKS WITH THE CONNECTIONS
ARE BURIED IN BENJAMINS.
UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THE PRIVILEGED
FEW BIDEN FAMILY’S, WALL
STREET PLUTOCRATS, THE BIG
TECH BILLIONAIRES AND THE HARD
LEFT SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS
LIKE B.L.M. WILL GET PAID BIG.
THAT IS NOT COMPASSIONATE.
IT’S NOT CARING.
IT’S CRUEL CRONYISM AND
HEARTLESS INDEFERENCE TO THE
WORKING PEOPLE OF -- INDIFFERENC
WORKING PEOPLE.
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE VOTED FOR.
THIS IS WHAT GEORGIANS VOTED
FOR IN JANUARY.
UNTIL WE VOTE AGAIN, THIS IS
WHAT WE WILL GET.
A TALE OF THE TWO SOCIETIES.
OF THE AVERAGE AMERICANS
SCRAMBLING TO STAY AFLOAT
WHILE ELITE; SUCH AS, BADE
BIDE’S FRIENDS AND FAMILY
ENJOY THE HIGH LIFE.
WE GET TO VOTE AGAIN IN LESS
THAN TWO YEARS.
THE MORE AMERICANS WATCH THE
TWO-TIERED ECONOMY, THE LESS